what do you call it here at the White
House when 10 000 people illegally cross
the border in a single day so what do
you call it Peter when GOP puts forth a
wait no no no no no no no no no you
can't I'm answering okay we're gonna
move no questions no no no no no no
we're moving on the background
no no I tried to answer Peter I tried to
answer the question you stopped me let's
go okay so there was footage yesterday
of border patrol cutting some of the
razor wire that Texas had installed
Governor Abbott has vowed to reinstall
it they have picked their his borders
are his pictures of people taking fresh
razor wire out to the border to
reinstall it is there now a federal
policy of removing the barriers that
Texas is installing so here's here's
what I I'll say I would have to look
into that I did so see those reports
yesterday but as it relates to Governor
Abbott we know what he has done this
past uh these past couple of years while
this president has been in office he's
he's turned this when it comes to the
Border he's turned this into a political
stunt and that's what he's done over and
over again that's what I can speak to I
did see those reports I would have to go
back and get a sense from the team and
give you an answer on that there's an
enormous amount of concern the mayor of
Eagle Pass tells us at least 5 000
people crossed probably yesterday or in
the last two days maybe a lot more what
I mean you've already talked a little
bit but what
resources specific to this surge are
being well I just laid out I just laid
out three additional announcement that
we did to deal with um to deal with the
border that we announced yesterday we
announced the TPS uh Venezuela uh
announcement as well yesterday and so
this is a president again that has taken
uh that has taken action without the
help of of republicans in Congress he
has taken action over and over again to
deal with this issue let's not forget
and you know this very well having uh
having as you're covering that region
that this is an issue that's been around
for decades this is a broken immigration
system this is why the president on his
first day put forth a comprehensive
piece of legislation to try to deal with
this immigration system we've put more
we put CBP 25 24 25 000 CBP agents out
there we try to make sure that we deal
with the smuggling that's happening
we've tried to make sure that we
continue to deal with this in a Humane
orderly way and that's what we're going
to continue to promise to do again we
just announced three more additional
enforcement
Pathways or ways to move forward on this
and so the president's going to continue
to do what he can from from the from
from this Administration
actually with the Border
um how many people coming into this
country illegally is enough President
Biden that
say that last one how many people come
how many people illegally coming into
the United States is enough for
president
enough for what 5.9 million people have
been encountered illegally I know the
numbers but enough for what
not just to stop the fluff as I
mentioned this is a problem that's been
around for some time now for decades a
broken system
the president has done everything and is
going to continue what to do what he can
without the help of some Republicans on
in in Congress to deal with this issue
and I just laid out what he has done
over the past two years right 24 000 CBP
agents and officers along the Southwest
border this is more a historic number
more than any other any other president
has been able to do and that's uh 26
2600 additional civilian Personnel those
are going to be helpful in dealing with
the issue increase border holding
capacity by 3750 to 22
700 and so we're going to deal we're
trying to deal with the smuggling issues
that we're seeing as well on the border
so the president's going to continue to
do the work he made some announcement on
as well yesterday as I just mentioned
and so look we're going to continue to
implement a strategy that is Humane that
is safe and that is orderly as it
relates to enforcement and so that is a
promise that you can see from this
president again
GOP the Republicans put out a continuing
resolution that actually reverses the
work that the president is trying to do
makes it the situation worse that's what
they were trying to push
and so look we would love to do it in a
bipartisan way and really fix this issue
that's been around for some time now but
right now the president is doing it on
his own I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis